ma buena sta tutta slauso amigos tutti
quanti Ciao salti su
wrestling previsione ragazzi ci passi e
come se ti metti di lato dai maledetto
pigro eh comunque a prescindere Aspetta
che c'è una cassa Qua c'è gente ecco che
sentivo ruggiti forti Ah quello è uno
grosso No è vero che mai visto Non è
vero che mi hai visto posso provare a
sfruttare un colpo di minchia questo è
veramente grosso un magnum
[Musica]
Non ci credo se può trasformare la merda
ha funzionato non è morto
Cioè non è morto con la magnum veramente
Ah ok adesso è morto quindi un colpo
della Magnum è un colpettino normale e
schiattano da meno male se no ne ho
sfruttato uno raga perché secondo me
questo questo era da sfruttare così
andiamo chiavi di lui Ah questo quindi è
il laboratorio teoricamente credo Eh non
lo so Morirete incazzate Quindi mi posso
togliere i parassiti però prima di farlo
Devo raggiungere Ashley potenziarsi
l'arma Beh l'arma base quindi la pistola
è la mossa perché poi dopodiché le
munizioni base che sono quelle della
pistola diventano fortissime Quindi
secondo me è stata la giocata però per
adesso non è ancora potenziata al
massimo quello è l'obiettivo
ora è morto Ammetto che siete tanti qua
dentro effettivamente però
non abbastanza per seccare me ok
gioielli zio e intendo Porca merda
con gioielli intendo le lacrime viola
ormai ragazzi permettimi in difficoltà
dovete lanciarmi 62 persone insieme
perché se no sono cazzi vostri Forse era
meglio non dire sta cagata va bene
a merda Questa
cazzo sei Matrix Come hai fatto a
schivarmi
questo è uscito da Borderlands raga è
uguale
Ok attenzione che sto finendo i colpi
però eh Stai attento Eccoli qua trovati
a posto con un detto
Uh Giochiamo a scacchi così sul
pavimento ad esempio ma un mercante qua
tipo per sbaglio un mezzo mercante
Porca [__] che ansia volevo dire che
spavento però ho detto che ansia Vabbè
più o meno comunque ci siamo perché mi
rende disless sono sono sono gli
straniero mi cucini una zuppa Non lo so
usa 900
usi il ticket poi usi i soldi me ne
fotto
un'arma di prima scelta Minchia adesso
la pistola leva il doppio Ma ragazzi la
mia pistola leva il doppio sono forte
fortissimo che giocatore fortissimo
ok
sì
nonna Sei tu Ho visto cose interessanti
andare di qua Ragazzi io tirerei fuori
un fucile a pompa ma per non saper né
leggere né Comunque è più forte la mia
pistola normale un altro po' di fucile a
pompa però dettagli
Buongiorno
E tu che cazzo è andato allora questo è
ho sbloccato la saracinesca di prima
quindi già posso tornare indietro ho
sbloccato sta porta posso aprire io apro
eh Ho aperto io me ne vado a prescindere
No perché di qua non ho controllato
Scusatemi Che cazzo c'è ma vedi che c'è
qualcosa qua che cacchio è sta roba
insufficient Power ah ah ah
Eccolo
fortissimo Non ho capito Che cazzo ho
fatto ma l'ho fatto sistema ripristinato
sicurezza ausiliaria non ho letto Vabbè
giorno ecco questa cosa che sto vedendo
fa molto schifo ad esempio però se non
ti muovessi sarebbe meglio Comunque
Madonna ragazzi ma che cazzo è è
terribile questo
che diavolo di esperimenti fanno Qui
tutto quello che dici Io l'ho già detto
io un secondo prima Comunque mi fa molto
ridere sempre 'sta cosa però non si
svegli si rigenerano al trans a meno che
i parassiti che risiedono nel tuo
organismo non vengono Distrutti a mirino
col mio sensore Ci vuole un minimo col
mio sensore per vedere i punti sensibili
Beh non vedo l'ora di ritrovarlo scheda
magnetica E perché proprio adesso ti
muoverai sto stronzo qua non si muove va
bene Molto strano
Buongiorno Ma che cazzo sei Non lo so
però io me ne vado dalle palle Ciao
gente Secondo me questo qua Ah sono
questi quelli che si rigenerano a
oltranza
A meno che i parassiti non vengano
rimossi io me ne fotto e me ne vado bene
Wow
sarebbe opportuno ma funziona No perché
non vedo la corrente Devo riattivare la
corrente Eh ho capito Lion
è morto non è morto
devo è che gli posso solo fermare Quindi
questi Minchia ma che brutta roba devo
togliere la corrente cioè devo riattiva
Scusate mi devo rimettere la corrente
nella congelatore vai
Mamma mia che brutta roba ragazzi che
brutta roba sto vedendo
bene
finché lo fermo va bene però poi il
problema è dopo continua a rigenerarsi
la roba cioè minchia terrificante raga
Che schifo Fai schifo
e mi servono altre due tessere in tutto
ciò pensate Oh chiudi la porta chiudi la
porta chiudi la porta chiudi la porta
chiudi la porta la porta chiusa bene
c'è un altro di stronzi eh devo stare
devo fare qualcosa qua
Ah sì mi serve si chiama magnetica
Processing adesso mi crea quella livello
2 No ragazzi no vi prego no vi prego no
ma che schifo merda ancora
E come lo secco
Ma si rigenerano il pranzo
Cosa devo fare Devo aspettare è questo
Ah questo lo devo fare prima magari non
dopo così tanto che cazzo ne so
mi sa che quello lo dovevo fare prima
posso entrare qua
Che cazzo è sta roba Non lo so
Non so cosa ho fatto ma ho qualcosa ho
fatto Grazie
arrivederci
Minchia che brutta roba Comunque
quell'affare mi permetteva di sbloccare
la porta Quindi teoricamente anche qua
le porte si sono sbloccate Apri sta
Porta de merda
Ok
Mamma mia ragazzi che brutta roba Meno
male che rimangono fuori non rimangono
fuori non rimangono fuori va bene non
rimangono fuori io che cazzo parlo a
fare
non è che posso andare avanti tutto il
gioco con questi che mi seguono però eh
fatevi una vita che
ci sono i nemici normali li sto sentendo
Eccolo qui lo zio Lo zio
lo zio Guarda sono quasi contento di
vederti Ti giuro Oh
Scherzavo non si può neanche fare una
battuta che devo dire allora ok ok Ok
Muori muori aspetta
allora
[Applauso]
perfetto
e anche oggi abbiamo risolto la
situazione bene
c'è una Ok perfetto sta stanza qua
magari non la apriamo Ah qua ci serve la
testa a livello 3 Porca [__] E dov'è
come faccio
devo ficcarla da qualche parte qua no no
no
Vi prego no ne sono due o cos'è Granata
frammentazione Beh dai Sicuramente
servirà molto Magari li indebolisce sul
serio però si rigenerano sempre quindi
non li posso seccare proprio in nessun
modo
soggetti in fugavano con sé va bene
cazzo me ne frega a me oh mirino con bio
sensore così teoricamente invece può
essere usato con qualsiasi arma
compatibile con i mirini Ok quindi lo
posso ficcare al allo Sting Esatto
vediamo
Oh bello così adesso vedo i parassiti
dove stanno quindi lo posso seccare
veramente
Mi serve una chiave inglese mi serve una
chiave inglese dov'è che sta Ok quindi
devo liberare sti stronzi perché la
chiave inglese è dentro uno di questi se
non ho capito male devo sparare
attraverso la teca può essere
Porca [__] Mi sa di sì
vabbè
merda merda
e sono morto hai anche le poppe
Ma niente Non riesco a colpire Non ce la
farò mai Dimmi te [__] della merda se
devo avere una Mira così scabrosa
Vabbè ragazzi non stavo scherzando eh
prima non è che tutto quello che dico
Dovete prenderlo sul serio per farmi
sentire un [__] ho capito Stavo
scherzando È difficile ok È difficile
Ecco la chiave inglese la vedo tra lui
va bene ok È morto è morto Grazie Kevin
utile questo che mi ha dato Rubino mi
conviene farli fuori perché danno un
sacco di roba quasi quasi faccio fuori
anche lui perché
mi danno un sacco di roba questi stronzi
sei riusciti va a fare in culo a colpire
una merda di punto ok Oh
[Applauso]
Basta finito grazie
alessandrite è una malattia una malattia
ne hai sputato un altro Ma sì dai
facciamoli fuori tutti ma chi se ne
frega ok
siamo a posto
Mi dai un uno Zaffiro tipo non Rubino
Vabbè io sono contento uguale un altro
No perché avete un sacco di roba utile
Ragazzi mi serve Vabbè va bene così
tanto ne arriveranno altri bellissimi ho
finito un sacco di punti ho fatto sarà
contento cioè un sacco di pescetas
adesso ficco questo nel mentre che fico
questo arriveranno in 12 mi Eccoli
perfetto lo sapevo io allora
puttanazza morto Oh Attenzione c'è una
bomba
Esplodi pezzo di merda no
vabbè vabbè
a posto
ok
ma non ci voglio uno ma colpito Che culo
che cazzo è affidata la scheda Minchia
mi sono cagato addosso sto esplodendo
qualcosa
se fosse esploso qualcosa non c'è finiti
cioè con Tizio
c'era
questi coltivare lanciarsi cose addosso
cosa succede stronzi poi comunque ok
a posto
quest'arma Quando c'è il calcio è
veramente troppo forte comunque cioè
perché è proprio molto più precisa di
una pistola normale senza una merda
Ok ciao
molto utile ragazzi
punticini thank you thank you grazie al
prossimo e mi serve che mi arrivino
altri giganti come quelli di prima
perché mi danno veramente la Madonna
però per ora Ok abbiamo Allora altezza
livello 3 possiamo tornare indietro ma
prima fatemi aprire questo che non so
cosa sia forse si ricongiunge Ah sì sì
era per farvi in fretta ok
Ok baby
questa roba l'avevo già aperta mi sa che
ce l'ho già passato di qua o no
qua per far nascondere Ashley Quindi no
non c'ero passato di qua ok
very nice la zia Dove sei qua dietro mi
sa eh
Madonna incredibile ho fatto dei giri
per arrivare a questa qua incredibile
ragazzi
si sveglia
Beh ti vedo bene Ti vedo bene
Sì dai tanto devi toglierlo pure a te il
parassita Quindi Già che ci sei bravo eh
però dobbiamo togliercelo
definitivamente Queste sono Cure
momentanee dobbiamo andare al
laboratorio di Louis
è una penna Comunque quella
biro in realtà è quello che ho fatto
Come ti senti Tachipirina
stavo già sentita
potresti urlare Ce la faremo per il per
il Meme però
non sbloccarle in faccia ti prego
è già tutto con una mano un fenomeno
come ti senti ma se aspettiamo un po'
più di tempo finito il capitolo Oh yeah
credo che manchino due capitoli ragazzi
14 e 15 Almeno sono riuscito a
potenziare la mia pistola prima della
fine che non è male
Madonna mi sono cagato nelle mutande Ma
sei stupida
Grazie prego
Ce la fai
Dov'è Luis
è finito male si è preoccupato per te
fino alla fine
andiamo Non c'è molto tempo
Facciamola finita
per lui
va bene
Adam ricevi c'è un laboratorio dove
rimuovere il parassita Ho il sospetto
che tu sappia dove si trovi
ok
ma in tutto questo condono che cazzo sta
facendo se posso chiedere
minerali di cristallo ho trovato un
sacco di roba che si veda un sacco
capitolo 14 No ragazzi pazzesco ho
trovato un sacco di roba me ne vado anzi
guarda vai là perché prima non ci potevo
salire adesso posso
sveglia da un minuto e già fa la
simpatica attenta sono una scassinatrice
Complimenti c'è anche il poligono
Madonna Pure qua il poligono hanno fatto
quindi questo è
anzi guarda ti vendo un sacco di roba
per adesso questo grazie
sempre a Palermo ce la faremo Sì sì sono
d'accordo Speriamo Secondo me
No non è vero che è morto lì
Vabbè dai Forse riesco a prenderlo lo
stesso se faccio il giro Sì questo si
apre allora
Oh merda Madonna che è pieno di gente
qua
caprone sa chi pezzo di merda Oh
Attenzione attenzione
da lontanissimo Ah devo ripararmi le
cose mi sono dimenticato Vabbè tanto il
Mercante della realtà e posso anche fare
so che sarei
tranchite quello che dici tu dov'è
merda questo c'ha l'armatura Non l'avevo
visto pure
e schioppa Madonna che fastidio e
andiamo lì sopra ragazzi per ora tutto
ok erbetta
Che minchia devo fare il giro e stai
zitta mi metti ansia Porca [__]
Salve Bravo zio
ti regalo
[Musica]
bene
Comunque ho notato che le granate a
frammentazione man mano sono diventate
sempre più Cioè credo che siano i nemici
diventati sempre un po' più resistenti
perché le granate prima shottavano
adesso non più ma giustamente
ci pensi c'è una logica dietro ok
Perfetto In tutto questo mi era mancata
esce mi era mancata un sacco adesso che
potrebbe morire da un momento all'altro
mentre non la vedo ok
Ok belli siamo troppo un sacco di roba
qua perfetto ah
cosa cazzo devi fare
Ah serve per ok e la lascio lì va bene
merda mi sa che deve venire in fretta
merda merda merda merda merda merda
merda merda merda merda merda merda stai
zitto dov'è
Ah è sceso quel merda Ok attenzione
[Musica]
Minchia non posso allontanarmi un attimo
comunque regà eh questa cosa è terribile
se ne sono andati Eccoli spider-man
Ok c'è anche l'altro di sopra No
Porca [__] Perché quando sono
impreparato c'è sempre qualcuno mi fa
spaventare sto cazzo già lei siamo in
resina eh non non so Happy Wheels vabbè
Questo l'abbiamo capito
va bene
perfetto
quanti cazzo siete ragazzi oh
Eh vabbè Madonna che mira di merda
Oh
Che cazzo è Che cosa è uscito la sta
merda oh
esci di attenta che qua è un casino
Porca [__]
E vabbè ma questo corre
botto teoricamente gli ho staccato e
mori
[__] sti cosi Oh ragazzi Ho finito
i colpi della pistola Ho quasi finito i
colpi della pistola devo stare attento
Eh devo stare molto attento cos'è che
c'è
le fogne C'è un topo
No dai poverino non ce la faccio Mi
dispiacerebbe troppo
Vabbè dai ho resistito alla tentation ed
era un topo finto Guardate come sono
Pro alla vita Ok ma poco però gli zombie
tranne quella di Ashley ce la fai
sì
perfetto
Ma fallo col piede allungati
veloce quanto tempo ma che cazzo stai
facendo
Ok Andiamo nello stesso momento
sì perfetto
la cosa più difficile del mondo vai
ficcati qua dentro eh che già ho capito
come va a finire qua che era nata
frammentazione chi cazzo esce da lì
Vabbè Ragazzi ho capito va Magnum subito
Ah no sono i miei amici ciao
Secondo me n'è uno anche dietro eh Non
voglio girarmi
[Applauso]
Oh merda è morto
[Musica]
Raga ma che cazzo è
è morto
e non muore Oh
adesso è morto
parte devo curarmi perché sto morendo da
Io praticamente
Ma che cazzo è successo ragazzi è morto
o no
adesso è morto però ci ha messo una vita
adorabile Berillo rosso esci ancora da
dentro Penso di sì va bene
mi serve che vieni qua No tutto a posto
Ho fatto molto di peggio Comunque adesso
si trasformano ulteriormente in cose
spinose
Minchia che precisione perfetto
quanto contenta la zia di aver fatto una
cosa da elementari
Meno male che non l'ho ucciso mi sarei
sentita in colpa per tutto il resto del
Gameplay qua non c'è corrente
Ah ok un altro di quei cosi da sbloccare
va bene va bene va bene Tanto ormai sono
Expert
gira il coso Pensaci tu Tanto
sicuramente mentre lo fai arriverà
qualcuno
no
Ah sì pensavo non pensavo ci fosse
qualcosa l'ho fatto solo l'ho fatta solo
sgobbare a caso va bene
pure ci manca solo quello Guarda Ok Ecco
la corrente Allora teoricamente se tolgo
energia a questo punto qua Arriva di là
e quindi in tutto questo adesso si
spegneranno le luci perfetto e qua
scenderà
Porca [__] il prossimo
là ma che cazzo fai là Ma sei scema
Ma scema Ma che cazzo fai lì Ma sei
stupida Ma perché sta tenendo il ponte
Porca merda mi sono ripreso lei
la vita scorre e lo sapevo
E vabbè finché arriva gente addosso e
sparo la gente no
Ok
qualcun altro perfetto
[Applauso]
è morto è morto tranquilla Ci ho fatto
io
dalla mia parte non è arrivato nessuno
Oh merda
Ma porca [__]
stai fermo
Sì sì arrivo arrivo arrivo arrivo arrivo
arrivo arrivo arrivo arrivo arrivo
arrivo arrivo arrivo
perfetto
esci ti dovresti tipo correre tipo
Brava cosa è morto Quello non è morto
No vabbè ma è incredibile
aspetta
non ci credo [__] Merda
Non ci voglio credere ragazzi lo sto
mancando lo sto mancando lo sto facendo
Che cazzo è uno su quattro
Ma che cazzo fai
uno su quattro che cazzo ho fatto ho
ammazzato un topo che è successo
Grazie veramente
un Berillo rosso va bene
Tutto a posto Esci tutto normale grazie
prego esci No grazie lei te lo deve dire
cazzo tu Ci mancherebbe solo perfetto eh
Che bordello sti cosi raga ogni volta
fatto sono fortissimo sono troppo forte
lo faccio in un secondo ragazzi ok E che
cazzo c'è qua dentro ah no solo roba Ok
non servono o Invece sì c'è una merda
due merde Madonna non so se mi fanno
schifo più questi io li insetti tipo
quelli che volanti
Mi sa che dovevo andare veramente di qua
Va bene
questa porta
è una richiesta fatta è finita per caso
Boh non mi fate domande ragazzi ah Ma
qua siamo dove eravamo prima qua sotto
dove andiamo
eh
che c'è
Oh che cazzo vuoi
che
e anche episodi oggi è giunto al termine
ragazzi Mamma mia che gioco della
Madonna però vedete sia piaciuto come se
vi è piaciuto
il video della descrizione iscrivetevi
al canale e noi ci vediamo come sempre
al prossimo episodio di Resident Evil
Beh ragazzi